You know,
history has tended to move people toward
mutual acceptance.
You might say,
you know,
in other words,
the moral compass has expanded,
uh,
over time.
If you compare us to the time back when
people in one hunter gatherer village
thought the people in the next village
or subhuman,
um,
that doesn't mean that continued
progress is,
is guaranteed.
Okay.
What is,
what is guaranteed?
And this is what's interesting to me and
this is,
this is what leads me to think that
it's,
it's not crazy to say that,
uh,
there's some larger purpose with a moral
dimension unfolding through human
history.
What,
What's interesting to me is that the way
history seems seems to kind of be set
up,
although I know set up is kind of a
biased a term because I'm,
I'm not sure that any anybody or things
set it up.
But,
um,
the,
uh,
the way the system works is that if
people don't make the moral progress,
they pay a price.
Okay.
So right now in the history of the
world,
if people in the different abrahamic
faiths,
Islam,
Judaism,
Christianity,
don't get better at accepting one
another,
don't get better at tolerance,
it can be really bad for the world on an
epic scale.
You know,
it could be,
we can be talking about the collapse of
the society and,
uh,
I think this is built into the system
and we've seen it time and time and time
again,
that history forces people to either
expand their moral compass or pay the
price.
And so all I can say for sure is that,
uh,
for pretty sure is that,
that I think the salvation of the world
in the sense of just holding the system
together.
You know,
having some degree of peace and order,
uh,
depends on further moral progress.
Uh,
that doesn't mean that the outcome will
be good.
But it's interesting to me that,
that the system drives,
drives us toward this point where we
either make the moral progress or we pay
the price.
So,
uh,
and this is actually reminiscent of
something that various biblical prophets
were kind of saying in one sense or
another.
And not just biblical prophets.
I mean,
I would say,
uh,
Mohammed,
I would say abrahamic prophets in
general.
A common message is to say that,
uh,
salvation is possible.
So long as you align yourself more
closely with the moral axis of the
universe.
Now usually these profits,
they didn't use the term moral access to
the universe.
Of course they use the term God,
but they did think of God as the moral
axis of the universe.
And I would say that even now,
even if you're secular,
uh,
you,
you can still that the salvation of the
world and this concrete sense of holding
it together,
um,
is going to depend on humanity,
aligning it self more closely with the
moral axis,
uh,
of the universe.
If you agree with me that that access
involves things like,
uh,
acceptance of people who are different
from you and,
and overcoming,
you know,
prejudices and biases.
And so on.